hey guys welcome back to another episode
of awesome build and as you may have
noticed this episode was actually
supposed to go up last week and I do
apologize for that I had some computer
issues so that's what kind of tied
things up a little bit but this is part
three of how to build a spaceship
corridor and we're just going to go
right into the footage to see what we
got
all right so here it is there are a few
things I would probably still add it's
probably about 98% complete is a few
things missin here and there that would
really kind of touch it up closing this
gap up here maybe by adding some piping
or even some more diffusion or something
like that to kind of add some more light
I ordered you guys even go heavy around
the detail there's a lot of elements on
the styrofoam and stuff like that where
you could add even more details using
little bits of plastic pieces and stuff
like that you have lying around and
little pieces of wire and even adding
more lights add you know it some more
cheap dollar store lights to different
elements and stuff like that put some
lights behind stuff to kind of
illuminate things from behind which kind
of gives it a cool look so for various
parts like the styrofoam a lot of these
were already had openings in them so I
wanted to put lights behind it to kind
of bring it out a little bit more give
the whole thing a little bit more life
so just by adding a light actually this
has a magnet already built into it so
that's kind of a nice feature so I could
just snap on there and cover it up now
you have a piece that's actually doing
something alright now for some of the
pieces that are just stare film they
have an interesting shape but they're
also usually pretty recognizable as just
being painted styrofoam unless you add
little elements to it and again I would
go even further than this but just
adding a little piece of cardboard with
some little interesting shapes and some
different colors added to it it kind of
takes your mind a little bit more away
from the fact that it's just a piece of
styrofoam and now it looks like
something that's doing something and
again if you had a cheap dollar store
light even better so once again all of
these things are very modular you can
rearrange stuff as you need
like I say without the lighter pieces I
used magnets and with the styrofoam and
for these heavier pieces or it's just
attached to a piece of MDF board or even
like a piece of cardboard but it's it's
heavier because you're adding
different plastic elements and stuff I
put these picture hanger piece on there
so it's just a bracket they're pretty
cheap I think they're probably about
five or six bucks at a hardware store
you might even be able to find them
cheaper but then you just add the
bracket to a bunch of different pieces
and then you can rearrange how you want
it to look so you could take this piece
down add another piece so on and so
forth and it takes no time to set back
up then as you can see I ran some LEDs
for the floor and again you can totally
change things up how much you guys
choose to put into it is purely up to
you the more you put into it the better
it's going to look obviously you don't
need a lot of money to build something
that looks impressive you just need some
time and a little creativity and it can
go a long way because all of this stuff
is just junk you know it's a couple of
Gatorade bottles glued together with
some hose attached to it it's like I
said egg cartons and old broken toys and
discarded yogurt cups but this gives you
an idea of how you can build a
relatively cheap spaceship corridor so
you guys shouldn't feel restricted by
what kind of money or what kind of a
budget you have or if you don't have any
budget in order to build this corridor
it was about a hundred dollars most of
the money went into building the actual
structure and just the lumber and even
that wasn't very expensive other things
that I just had lying around I added
those elements too and those are things
that maybe you won't have I took bits
and pieces of other projects and added
stuff but for the most part all of the
elements that I use to dress up the
interior of it were just pieces of junk
they were just things that you would
normally throw away the styrofoam all of
the plastic elements the cups and the
different containers and stuff all those
little bits and pieces of plastic or
wiring that I use to kind of dress it up
are just things that I save for projects
like this or if you want to build a
project like this and you don't
necessarily have it any time restraint
you have plenty of time to gather some
of this stuff like I said it was
probably about three or four
months of me saving up those plastic
containers and stuff like that and I
still have bins full that I can use for
other stuff so this is just a small
fraction of the stuff that I actually
have that I've been saving up to use
mostly because this is just a small part
of a much larger piece that I'm gonna be
working on now how you choose to layer
corridor is totally up to you and
depends on the project if you want it to
look much brighter you absolutely can
you can add more lights now as you guys
may have noticed I took out my panels
that I originally had here and I added
one long thinner panel so that I could
add my windows like these window pieces
are just cardboard with the window cut
out and some plastic on there to act as
a diffuser now you could just as easily
do that on the bottom instead and have
those panel pieces up here and have your
lights on the bottom and kind of light
your subject from underneath which I
think would actually be pretty cool and
probably give a very dramatic look for
whatever your subject is inside your
corridor you can also just because the
ceiling is removable you could take the
ceiling out or cut panels for the
ceiling and light it from the ceiling if
you wanted to you could even run LEDs
underneath your floor and light some of
your elements from underneath which
would look really cool and give it sort
of a sense that you're maybe just on one
deck and that there's another deck below
you by being able to remove the ceiling
or remove a wall and gives you the
flexibility to use your camera angles a
lot more you can shoot stuff from a
little bit further but you can get some
wider shots from the side if you wanted
to you can shoot your subject from
overhead you can it would be a lot
easier if you're shooting more than one
subject in the corridor like two people
having a conversation if you're removing
one wall then you have that opportunity
to shoot the two people side-by-side
rather than having to use like really
intense close-ups or over the shoulder
shots you can go for a little bit wider
shot and capture them both against one
wall or as I said you can get some
really cool dramatic overhead shots you
can bring the dolly in and get some
really cool fluid smooth shots and stuff
like that yeah
you can get some kind of need dramatic
shots of you know just the feet walking
on the corridor
so if you wanted to you could expand on
your existing corridor or build a facade
or a wall or something like behind it or
a door or by putting a green screen back
there you could duplicate it in After
Effects or even you know build a
Photoshop version of the rest of your
corridor or a door that you can animate
or something like that all those things
kind of pen down your budget and your
skill level we are going to be using the
set piece for a variety of different
projects we have coming up including
Estelle genetic episodes and as I said
I'm going to be using it for a project
that I'm going to be working on in the
future and I will keep you guys a little
bit more updated on that as it gets a
little bit closer a little bit further
along so this will probably be a piece
that we revisit a little bit in the
future but I hope that you guys have
enjoyed the build so far and I hope it
inspires you guys to go out and build
some stuff of your own once again thanks
so much for watching and supporting the
show don't forget to share it and tell
your friends and you can look me up on
Facebook at James and Jim J Russ and
once again guys thanks so much you guys
are awesome I'll see you next time
you